Luke Evans as long entertained audiences
on the West End and the silver screen
playing characters including a Gaston in
Beauty and the Beast to name but one for
the first time he's also recorded a
studio album reimagining some classics
from across genres including the title
track at last and this famous ballad
studio has been signing copies with CD
for people in art gallery forgetting a
previous conference you do a little bit
of that reimagining classics songs that
you've chosen because you like them or
because they suit your voice a bit of
both actually songs I've sung for a very
long time
things I like to sing one of my own
things I've sung since I was a teenager
and weirdly a lot of DeMars songs sung
by women that have never been covered by
men which is a strange thing that only
happened but when we brought the the
number of 60 songs I chose down to 12
and realized 80% of them will buy by
women so that was an interesting thing
in itself it took a different life it's
tracked with that when you hear the word
sung by a man and the song has been
rearranged temp has been restructured
orchestration they just sound very
different which is an interesting
approach it's just it's just a hobby I
don't mean that facetiously because
you've really built a quite a body of
work in films you're broken in you've
done some you know box office stuff
you're an established screen star you
don't need to go in a new direction if
it's not in a direction that's the thing
most people most people would have the
same reaction because they know me from
my movies but I actually was a singer
before I was in a film actor western
stuff Western stuff and before that I
sang in the valleys of South Wales I
used to do I stared for its competition
singing was my dream it's always been
the thing I've loved the most so really
it's full circle to actually get to do
the album but the album only really has
come about because of what I've done on
film and getting an international
profile more people want to hear me sing
so it's all helped each other you know
we talked about singing in Wales my good
friend gets depressed now the
National Match in Cardiff when they have
to help the crowd along who said and
that idea of the chapel call you require
whatever it was that amazing coral
tradition in Wales what's its current
state of health oh I think it's probably
the live and kicking especially with how
great our Welsh rugby team has been
playing there was a little cup yeah yeah
we there's nothing quite like being in
in what I call Cardiff Arms Park but
it's now the Millennium Saviour the
Principality Stadium but hearing the
anthem being sung and the hymns being
sung it's a lovely thing that is
generational it doesn't matter what
generation you are it still everybody
knows those songs and it's just so good
for you isn't it somebody told me other
day that when you get people together in
a choir and they sing for a bit it's
therapy well it's therapy and it's
actually it's it's physiological as well
as psychological in the sense that you
can actually measure their heartbeats
right coming into sync yes it's true
it's true there's a vibration that it
only happens when you sing when you sing
something that you're passionate about
and it's a beautiful melody it can carry
people along you know and I hope some of
the songs on this album will do the same
thing when you listen to them you know
there really are some of the people know
but sound very very different yeah and
I've been told we need to play it in
some Beauty and the Beast as well how
did you find that film I was living at
Disney like six months it's fantastic
and bringing to life in a human form a
character that people have known from
this a very famous animation was it was
absolute joy you know and it and the
world loved it you know we we traveled
with it and we took it around different
countries and had the same reaction
every where I went and now it's the
character the most people remembering
before and kids now know who I were
before this they didn't really know me
you know we'll see instances of
recognition of us three three years old
episodes yeah well yeah it's really
unbelievable when the press conference
is running we were talking about life on
the road which you know endlessly
appears glamorous to people who don't
have to endure it but actually it's it's
it's not all that fun no I mean listen
I'm not gonna moan about it I could be
doing something way worse but living out
of a suitcase for maybe ten months of
the year and you know not having the
creature comforts and being able to do
the things that everybody else gets to
do see
friend see their families I sacrifice
that a lot of the time because of being
on the road but you know it's cuz I have
a shelf life do you get to the end of it
think I'm just I'm hacked off for this
day I want to know I try and balance it
out I mean I'm still loving what I do I
really love what I do I'm very lucky to
do with it to tell stories for a living
and you know entertain people but it's
about is finding a balance it's hard to
find a balance in my business but you
know I try I try and do that and I'm
taking a trip to for Christmas and going
away so this time of year that actors
don't really work very much in film but
that was mostly look we're going to put
we plugged your your album are going to
plug our Studios at Elstree would you
get which are gonna be built fairly soon
2,000 jobs three billion pound
investment in the British film and
content production industry brewed state
of health or the moment that you very
much so probably better than any any
time before I mean it's we make some of
the biggest movies in the world I've
shot we shot Beauty and the Beast at
Shepperton and you know big Hollywood
movies are shot not just in the UK but I
just did a leonis the second season of
the alienness which we shot in Budapest
Europe and the UK we're all you know
we're next like the big Hollywood really
we make all the movies big movies you've
still got an appetite for the big films
I have a 2020 is packed for me with film
projects and they're really exciting two
exciting products I'm producing as well
so I'm mixing all that up and then I'm
taking this on tour in April I'm doing
for four big dates one of the Palladium
in London in April late April so I'm
very excited about that and and I'm just
juggling a lot you know and staying
staying busy came out of mischief
speaking keeping out of mischief you
could just tell Sarah to come collect
her signs you just got yourself a signed
CD here we go who is Sarah she works in
the gallery what are you doing there
Sarah I'm never quite sure co-directing
what you do do I come by actually they
did a bit Kevin's thanks very much
thanks for coming